so uh you can always you can maintain
position you can advance position and
you can tactically read position okay so
that's what we're doing here because
anyone who gets a close guard on you has
training
it's not natural behavior remember how
many times you were told to begin or
cross your ankles okay so if you feel a
closed guard that person has training
okay so oops
move break and clear
bicep we can do this one too I'll just
shove his head in
the boom head on the street up same
exact thing on your house
I want y'all alternating
so bicep pin
out
head on the street boom
up
out okay let's go
all right so because people now train in
a style and they you get locked in a box
so a lot of times
uh people are training ground fighting
will rely on the assumption that you
want to ground fight and so you can get
up a lot easier than you've used to
maybe 20 years ago okay so you always
want to look for that okay so as I boom
get up
and now I'm gonna I'm gonna measure him
okay so he's gonna want to aggress again
boo and I'm looking for some boot to
face okay
boom
pop measuring boom so this is a front
kick he tries a different way I don't
know if you can but we'll see
a measuring
round kick
[Music]
round kick okay let's try it okay so you
have some G Wasa in the middle of this
thing because I don't get to decide how
he gets up okay he decides how he gets
up but you want to understand the
Tactical architectures of the kicks that
you have so as I move out if you're
coming down the center line I want to
protect the center line my round kick
won't do that
okay back down
if he's turning away from me
do you see my front kick if I miss
this way follow the foot
but big heavy heavy Danner boot laces
and all boom instead to the head that's
going to work you see that if he's
slightly at the angle to me
do you see that that's where your round
kick comes in he's at an anger to you if
he's close to me you're going to turn
towards me he's closed boom that's where
your knee kit comes in okay don't try to
kick like that
okay so you have ranges and you have
your architectural elements to abide by
all right let's try it don't kick the
butt that's over the Decades of training
people they always kick your butt the
butt's not a Bible Target okay
um a lot has to depend on Footwear too
so here's my and again you should if
you're into self-defense you should wear
boots you could fight with Okay so this
toe is very hard I might not be able to
get his head
you see because the balance is stuff so
you kick that toe
boom right into the ribs okay so you're
not doing it instead you're not even
doing the ball of the foot just boom
that spear right in the ridge pop as
opposed to
doing this kind of stuff it's not really
power there and you're going to block
your leg you see so it may be wow right
here in the ribs
with the toe part of your boot okay
that's possible but but is not viable
okay and then be careful on your rounds
that the shoulders aren't blocking you
see